are we coming up on the little sister
seem like it's we're almost there I
think so
which one just drink toilet whiskey I
did now a favorite brand its 1960 Jean
Luc we're in the mid-atlantic and that
means actually that has nothing to do
with what we're doing right now welcome
back to potato mode this is the first
episode after maybe about I think it's
been like almost a month since we last
played something on this show but we are
back and you know what I am really happy
because we are playing some Bioshock
today oh man this was one of the most
visually stunning games on camera like
seriously if he's like just for the
intro or just from this whole entire
like openings opening sequence yeah it
looks amazing
he'll probably have some of the best
water so in the best water I'm not sure
how much of its still intact right now
because usually in potato mode we take
it from the highest settings to the
lowest so gradually but I think we're
just gonna start off with the lowest you
know it's been a while since we've done
this so let's just get back straight
into potato potato for everybody so far
it seems the same I remember there being
more texture on that purse but it could
be fine yeah I think it looks good oh
you know what oh what is it this is uh I
forgot about this on modern Windows 10
there's a bug with the audio that you
have to like do a bunch of settings to
mess it with really yeah well I guess
we're doing that then I remember that
was part of the reason I was excited for
the remaster it was like oh cool I don't
have to do that stupid audio fix anymore
see audio solution here yes alright we
got fire we got water we got plane
debris all over the place and we got up
a whole lot of mess going on here oh my
god we got like the mirror deflection
the water now is just like oh there's
normally like a skybox whoa
is this like a sheet of glass basically
and just reflecting it perfectly oh oh
well so that is a real-time reflection
because the reflection looks just as as
bad yeah as the so I guess props to them
good looking look at the plane a little
bit to the right yeah oh is it sinking
oh it's slowly going down I'm watching
goodbye everybody
by plane the famous no God's no Kings
only only potatoes they just had some
budget cuz they forgot to difficult to
Brighton they forgot to hire the
contractor to paint the actual words on
their hangout the ribbon will be good
we're fine we will add that later and
then and then they all died
can't wait till we get in there little a
little bubble oh look at this that
lighting it just stops it's like a
little veil ooh it's much a rectangle
alright that sound like the like
presentation even showing up I would I
would not take that bet at all no
presentation you got nothing so while we
are staring at this white screen I'm
just gonna go mention real quickly in
previous episodes of pity potato mode we
kind of just you know explored the game
once we got the settings down and we
didn't really have like a good idea of
what we're doing but I think going for
it it's good if we have like a goal in
mind right now so I was thinking like
we'll play until we find like a big
Daddy mm-hmm and hopefully we'll be able
to kill him and then that will be it
right how's it sound we try it by the
way can we skip this no no okay
well know that you can just get cozy oh
there we go
rapture welcome to crap sure I got a
minute this doesn't actually look that
bad it kind of works
well it's only because it's like under
the sea right and everything's gonna
look all like you know fade it anyway
half the signs are gone that one's gone
the fleet halls is still there perfect
the rest are Hertz non-existent that's
something I actually really find
fascinating from doing these episodes is
you get to figure out like oh well that
was like actual like geometry versus oh
that was just a texture yeah that's
completely gone and kind of seeing that
difference it got is the the Lighting's
weird cuz the like the gold thing yeah
kind of is this supposed to be like
mostly darkness you're supposed to be
mostly dark ah the famous pull down pull
down those shades
let some light in and then just throw up
at all the textures that you're seeing
here yeah like all the god rays are like
I guess they're but like it doesn't the
effects not the same there used to be
like music reflection in the water yeah
on the ceiling and stuff these had words
on them so you know a lot of people
protesting about a lot of nothing I'm
afraid
Joey this is a wordless City now from
now on yeah all the really cool signs
that were just people put a lot of care
into you they're just gone we don't need
it
ah the Train this is the
anti-intellectual utopia here banning
all books all words like stolen radios I
guess also I back in the day when the
remaster came out I did a graphics
comparison I remember that I'm just
thinking about like doing it now like
alright got let's sit here and line up
the shot with the nothing this is giant
squares just like oh those are the light
shafts right landing on them oh yeah or
me but it could be the rubble and I'm
not I'm not exactly sure I'm not sure
what that is actually it might be the
rubble assist let's say it's the rubble
and spare ourselves oh there's supposed
to be like a whole mural with a girl
like a lightning bolt and that's why
it's blinking that's not there anymore
same with that so the hands there but
they were like lightning right here
that's just not there that was like a
texture Wow
all the statues look even creepier I
can't wait till you get to a little
sister in the Big Daddy oh we're gonna
get to that in a second actually it's
better you yell it's funny how you can
actually see more the detail on those
guys on the splicers looks like someone
plugged up all his little portholes like
silly putty
Oh that'll give us an advantage later
all right all right let's get going oh
no not the law or the beautiful waters
showpiece we've ruined it
oh it's just oh yeah the game is all
about water undersea my bad it's all
gone there's like a water spray but you
can't even see it yeah there's a man you
still got the fish though that's the
most important part oh god I gotta say
the mood lighting doesn't work when it's
just a bunch of no it is also just like
kind of obscuring most of the view I'm
really creeped out is just kind of
confused hello
and the one-two punch
all right yeah this game is sort of like
a lot of the stories told through
environmental storytelling yeah on the
walls that we've just completely
destroyed yeah like what happens when
you take an immersive sim and just get
rid of the immersiveness of it right I
know you can see look like oh yeah I
mean like for that uh please that that's
just a mound of flour or something I
know but like look how it sort of it's
like moving it's like yeah there's
something going on there that's weird
that guy's already like that right Oh
kind of I'm pretty sure right like
there's no way the rest of the game
wouldn't do that and also for this giant
statue I guess because it I feel like he
probably worked better at the textures
because he doesn't look right or are we
coming up on the little sister seem like
it's we're almost there right I think so
which one just drink toilet whiskey I
did now a favorite brand all that looks
like the perspective looks weird without
any lighting oh good yeah it's like the
fool she's floating yeah off the ground
god all right get comfy
[Music]
No
god it's not like we're good now yeah
used to play this game where I would
actually turn off the objective marker
yeah and you just kind of cuz the way
the game is designed like oh you read
the sign and you know like this is ready
to go yeah can't do that with this I
just would not work you can still try
extra extra challenge mode right there
you go
based on my own memory oh you put a hole
through this nice painting just smear of
bees yes yes so haven't you ever heard
of modern art I'm that stop shock I'm
about one so you have one bullet left
it's got a save in the left whoa
what did I just do did I quit the game
did you oh my god ah dang it
where are we we're back at the beginning
of the bathroom man that's okay you know
what this is actually perfect because
this was my original idea for this
episode yeah we'll make this a bow shock
double feature
we're out of time right now so we'll
continue our journey this time to
Colombia next Friday on potato mode see
you then
we got a gun latest in the nerf line if
I out the bioshock nerf line of weapons
it says right-click show disabled this
has also been a tutorial on how to get
your sound working for bioshock 1 for a
Windows 10